Seigneur bon appétit merci quatre amis
réunis autour d'un repas péruvien un
Lecce des tigré une marinade de poisson
au goût corset pour agrémenter une
discussion qu'il est tout autant
au niveau des ministres et les congrès
ça c'est notre chose il est dû n'est pas
d'accord les nouvelles de leur pays
d'origine le Pérou les inquiète et
chacun à son opinion
40% des pauvreté dans notre pays c'est
gravement cher
un président destitué par un congrès
qu'il a tenté de dissoudre
l'écarter du pouvoir pour la troisième
fois en 18 mois et de gros Castillo est
emprisonné depuis le 7 décembre il est
accusé de rébellion et de conspiration
le Pérou y a un problème maintenant
politique économique et sociale
une crise qui a fait descendre des
milliers de péruviens dans la rue
aujourd'hui
déclare s'identifie s'identifier avec
les manifestations actuelles les
manifestants se rassemblent dans la
capitale Lima est revendique désormais
une nouvelle élection une assemblée
constituante pour modifier la
Constitution et la démission de l'actuel
présidente di naboloate
face justement la répression aux morts
et dans un contexte où la précédente et
la commence à gouverner avec le
Parlement hautement des légitimés donc
9% d'approbation mais aussi l'armée et
la police les manifestations augmentent
on voit qu'elle touche de plus en plus
de provinces et de plus en plus de
blocages
depuis un an ce doctorat en ingénierie
porte un regard désabusé sur la
politique de son pays cinq présidents
sans précédentes
dans les périodes 6 6 années et pour lui
les manifestations n'y changeront rien
maintenant avec cet autre gouvernement
peut-être
une fenêtre pour aller et pour commencer
de faire des départs pour l'avenir
peut-être je pense que mon pays
depuis quelques années
aujourd'hui
peut-être un pays fragmenté pour moi
s'accordent sur une chose le rejet de la
division et du clivage politique qui
mine le peuple on a la drogue extrême
puis la gauche extrême alors le peuple
qui sort se manifester il est un
sandwich au milieu là ils sont pas
d'accord sont doux extrémistes ils ne
cherchent que leur bien-être
s'intéresse pas un peuple s'intéresse
pas au pays là c'est ça la réalité la
discussion se poursuit sur les
revendications de justice sociale des
manifestants et déborde sur la nécessité
de réviser les privilèges accordés aux
compagnies minières internationales sans
oublier de blâmer le désengagement de
l'élite politique si tu es un politicien
mais toi tu es pantalons moi je suis là
le peuple moi choisi parce que j'ai
offert ça ici